[Music]
so consider for a second the value of
search how timely and relevant responses
bring value to your life then consider
other Google properties mail Guu Gmail
Chrome YouTube Android and play next
consider that Google delivers these
services on a daily basis to a billion
of our fellow users and underpinning
these services are a set of key
innovations and infrastructure that
drive them our goal at Google cloud is
to share these innovations and
infrastructure with you so that you can
create value and delight your customers
I'm Bobby and I'm joined by my colleague
oz and today we would like to talk to
you about a critical piece of this
infrastructure the Google global network
more specifically we'd like to talk to
you about Andromeda Andromeda is a
network virtualization platform for
Google cloud we'd like to show you how
you can use Andromeda to deliver network
services that are fast reliable and that
scale before we get started we'd like to
get acknowledged the work done by the
Andromeda team more specifically this
presentation is based on their paper
that they presented at the Usenet
conference for an STI it's really a
privilege for us to be in front of you
and to share the work done by this great
team of engineers and many unsung heroes
that work tirelessly in terms for
delivering these network services day in
and day out how many of you have seen
this network this slide by now right
but it bears worth repeating right
we've got hundred thousand miles of
fiber both terrestrial
as well as submarine right it's
extremely well provisioned 20 regions
around 125 plus points of presence or
more than 50 to interconnect points all
which gives you connectivity close to
where you are
connectivity close to where your
customers are right and you can get high
availability because you can multi-home
to any of these two regions or three
regions and get pretty significant
availability moreover we've designed
this network from the day up for
performance and scalability so we
control the point where you onboard on
this network we control the network and
the data centers so at the end of the
day you end up with a very compelling
user experience and we are building this
out even more and investing in bringing
it out
so I referred to as innovations in
networking the first thing I'd like you
to note and contrary to popular belief
is that we are still innovating in
networking you might have heard a mean
Vedad talk about some of these
innovations what's interesting that he
describes is that a lot of this
innovations in networking were actually
driven by the innovations and
distributed services that you know were
powering those services with the billion
plus users and he said that those
distributed systems required such
significant bandwidth that we just could
not buy a network that was enough to
meet our requirements so we had to go
and build it and I'm and so these are
some of the innovations as a result of
that I'll cover some of them in the next
slides but I'd like you to take a moment
and notice some of the key commonalities
underpinning many of them yes it is
software-defined networking the basic
idea between software-defined networking
is that you have a centralized control
plane that provisions and controls the
networking elements for providing
connectivity from end-to-end and
enforces policy you see a lot of those
big problems
we're become tractable when you have a
logical centralized brain that takes
actually control away from the
networking elements provisions them and
again enforces policy our Andromeda is
also based on a software-defined
networking architecture so what is the
Google Network look like right the
innovations that I was referring to our
data center network Jupiter it's
actually a photogate data center
class-based fabric it's also Sdn based
we have over a better bit of second put
a bit per second of total by sectional
bandwidth connecting these data center
fabrics are our ran network the B for it
too is an SDN network and it too has
extremely high throughput of the order
of terabytes
b2 connects our Google to the backbone
it's protected with very high SL ease
and what we do is we try to carry
traffic as much over our well
provisioned backbone and well provision
network before handing it off to the
internet so that your experience is as
optimal as possible espresso is our Sdn
to the peering edge what it does is it
actually with the advantage of Sdn
dynamically chooses from where we serve
our customers based on end-to-end
measurements so it's not always the most
proximate exit point but because of Sdn
we're able to choose what's the most
optimal in terms of user experience
based on availability and latency so
this is what our Google Network looks
like so if you were to take and come and
have a piece of Google Cloud what would
some of your requirements be some
extremely basic of course you need
multi-tenancy you need functional as
well as performance isolation you need
it to be highly available you need
elastic network services that help you
load-balanced protect using firewalls
and ACLs
connect to your on-prem and of course
monitor you need us to be agile in our
future delivery and iterate and improve
and scale and deliver these services to
you last but not the least and a key
portion of the stock is that you have to
we have to make it scalable so how do we
get there before I dive in this question
let me ask you what thoughts come to
your mind when I mentioned VP see
virtual private cloud because you see
VPC has different connotations in
different context at Google VP C's are
global it's a global model you don't
it's not isolated you don't have
regional replication of configuration
and connectivity it's also shareable you
can have one policy globally and but you
can also have the advantage of
fine-grain I am rules and of course on
the VP C we give you access to Google's
differentiated services I'm going to
talk about Andromeda in the next section
but essentially we help you get there to
get these network services by running
your global V PC on Andromeda so like I
had mentioned Andromeda is our network
virtualization for Google cloud what do
I mean by network virtualization it
essentially refers to having multiple
virtual networks right that essentially
run on top of a shared physical network
on a virtual network you can have
multiple VMs that essentially talk to
each other and these physical VMs in
turn run on a physical network the IP
addressing scheme of a virtual network
is totally decoupled from a virtual
network forwarding in virtual networks
is done by means of a V switch a V
switch essentially has a mapping of the
destination BM address to the actual
physical hosts IP address packet
forwarding happens essentially
like it does with all Network overlays
using encapsulation you encapsulate the
customers IP packet into another IP
packet with the transport header meant
for the destination IP address of the
host so now this is where the fun stuff
counts
what does Andromeda architecture look
like the Andromeda architecture is based
on a hierarchy of control planes and
data planes at the top of the control
plane hierarchy are our virtual machine
controllers these virtual machine
controllers receive an abstract
representation of the network specifying
what are your QoS rules what are your
firewall rules what are your routes
what are your subnets what are the VMs
etc it then translates that into open
flow commands to the virtual switches
you see in the gray below it does not
directly communicate with the virtual
switches but it goes through through a
proxy called the open flow front-end
these open flow front ends serve two
purposes one it serves to decouple and
the OpenFlow protocol from the Andromeda
control plane it also has no state it
essentially just translates the open
flow config commands into OpenFlow
protocol commands because it has no
state it serves as a static connection
point for the V switches to the network
because of that you can potentially
upgrade the control plane without
affecting the V switches below the V
switches have a control plane based on
the you know the standard
standards-based open flow V switch but
we've added proprietary extensions for
delivering some of our network services
now a key takeaway from this slide is
that our VMC controllers are sharded or
partitioned and that helps you get
scalability right if you want to bring a
new rack online all you have to do is
spin up a new job for a virtual machine
controller some open flow front ends and
voila you're up and running
each instance off of VMC is also
replicated there are three instances one
master to stand by using the taxes
protocol so having it sharded I mean
having it replicated gives you high
availability
so our VMC essentially our whole control
plane is highly available and does scale
out now moving on to our data plane if
there's one thing I'd like you to take
away of our data plane and unit you
what's unique about our data plane is
that it is a very performant OS by past
user space architecture running on a
dedicated CPU core when I say fast even
though it's running on user space we can
hit about three million packets per
second it's crafted very optimally by
taking advantages of things like you
know memory locality avoiding
synchronization like locks and taking
advantage of large page sizes and
avoiding thread handoffs and avoiding
system calls doing end-to-end batching
all to make it extremely fast now it's
also extremely secure remember this is a
process running in user space there is
no root access in addition the code is
so constrained that it's attack surface
is also very limited we also implement
the best-of-breed security practices
such as address space layout
randomization and you know having stack
Canaries all to prevent stack overflow
so net-net it's an extremely secure
process one point I should mention is
let's contrast this implementation of
the data plane with other alternatives
one thing you could do with the data
plane is implement it in a kernel or you
could implement it in hardware the
challenges with those are if you have a
crash in the data plane in a kernel you
take the whole system out and you know
god help you if you have it in the data
and the hardware last but not the least
it's also robust when a process it's a
user space
so you can restarted the control plane
just detects that the user space has
crashed and you can restart it very
easily in addition we have mechanisms by
which you can upgrade do a hitless
upgrade of the data plane process so
net-net
we can effectively roll out a data plane
change every week be agile and have many
rapid releases on the data plane so with
this control and unique data plane what
are some of the network services enabled
by ntarama de you of course mention
isolation as your requirement we'll see
some of these services and how Andromeda
enables some of these services but two
key takeaways are we make them very
highly available and there is no choke
point there is its key it's an
architecture that scales out very well
so diving right in how do you get
functional oval isolation functional
isolation it's a standard overlay model
where you encapsulate your customer IP
packet and you know the other outer IP
packet and essentially get and caps
functional isolation that way
performance isolation you know when I
mentioned that the data planes were
hierarchical the control and data planes
are hierarchical even the data plane has
the following paths we have the fast
path this is for your performance
critical path it has fixed cycle budget
and there is isolation by TX and rx
for that in addition there are certain
networking features that are obviously
CPU intensive that will take more than
necessary cycles than usual for those we
have the CPU intensive path and the way
we implement them are per VM threads CPU
attributed to the VM container for those
more CPU intensive operations this
essentially you know allows us to be
more fair because it's a per VM thread
with attributes for that fairly
allocated for that can
in addition having the cpu-intensive
path helps us to decouple the feature
velocity from the fast path so typically
you're not modifying the fast path when
you want to add new features you
typically add new features there are
more performance intensive with the FIR
view per VM thread so you maintain both
feature velocity as well as not disrupt
the core fast path functionality there's
also something called hoverboard I'll
discuss this a little further down the
road but it's essentially a dedicated
software gateway for processing the long
tail flows the long tail flows now I
before I I kind of gave the answer away
but essentially how many of you remember
the specter bug right mind melt so if
you remember when we hit that bug we
were able to upgrade our infrastructure
and just let you guys our customers our
users know that we had upgraded that
there was an issue we had upgraded it
and the way we were able to upgrade the
infrastructure without disruption was by
using live migration what is live
migration is which is essentially
migrated one VM to another machine with
extremely minimal blackout period
whereas Andromeda come into the play
Andromeda facilitates live migration
even across clusters if you step back a
little bit right if you think of a
global routing plane and routing
converges enabling us to do and the time
it takes for a routing to converge the
time we are able to do this VM migration
across clusters is pretty impressive and
like I said it's useful for you know
maintenance upgrades optimizing the
placement of VMs and of course fixing
the zero date bugs under the cover the
way Andromeda does this is it
essentially directs the migration source
host which to help in all traffic that
it receives from other gateways and
horse hosts to the target switch during
the blackout period
after the blackout period ends it then
instructs all other VMs and our gateways
to then send traffic to the target
switch so this is an amine this is a
very useful feature for us you know
maintaining high availability and
resiliency now going on to the network
services that are referring to internal
load balancing it essentially helps you
scale and grow your services behind a
virtual load balancing IP address that
are only accessible from the backend
instances you know inside the Google
Network inside your customer network
it's all I mean it's mostly RFC 1918
addresses so you use an RFC 1918 bib for
this purpose we support in a load we
support health checks and we preserve
the client IP what's important to note
is that internal load balancing has no
middle proxy there is nothing called an
actual internal load balancer right so
traditionally you had a VIP you had an
actual proxy instance I did the load
balancing to your backends but the wave
GCP does this internal load balancing is
that the load balancing functionality is
directly embedded and programmed in the
client VM itself so flows the load
balancing decision happens in the client
VM itself and it then gets erect it then
gets sent to the appropriate back-end
what this means is that we can scale out
our load balancer without having any
choke points the way it works is
essentially the controller's program the
open flow rules into the client VMs it
associates the backend VMs with the VIP
the open flow there are certain
proprietary extensions in terms of doing
you know sticky load balancing because
you have to do both connection tracking
as well as doing consistent hashing to
essentially get the load balancing
function that is both scaleable fair
also resilient to outages we support
health checks that track the state of
the backend instances and this is
essentially what the control plane for
an IL b looks like now
you have to connect on prem typically
you use either a physical router that
has both you know support for bgp and
VPN functionality and the BGP portion of
that a gateway learns your on-prem
routes and then the data plane of that
gate Bay encrypts it using IPSec VPN and
then sends it across the tunnel we took
a slightly different approach we could
have of course just deployed this
instance but in order to make your
router both scale and make it highly
available we actually took the routing
piece and made it a separate job a lot
of our implementations are essentially
just you can think of it as jobs running
in our fabric this cloud router job
peers with the BGP on-prem learns the
routes and then it programs those routes
to the VM selling them that in order to
reach your customer data center send the
packets directly to the VM so what is
this by you you essentially get a
separation of the control and data plane
hence you get more resiliency you know
when I talk about high availability what
this translates to is that you have
essentially VPN jobs or router jobs that
are available in a pool when we have a
command to create a VPN or create a
router the config manager essentially
instructs let's say for a router the
routing manager to allocate a router
from this pool of router tasks and
assigns them to that job the routing
manager then talks to the fabric manager
and Andromeda control plane
setting up the associations between the
router and the VMS right now should a
router process crash it's fine because
the data plane continues to forward
packets as before
till the bgp whole time the routing
manager which is tracking the routing
instance detects that the current router
has gone away spin supper new routing
instance and essentially reestablishes a
relationship so you have high
availability and no downtime even if the
control plane of the router crashes
similar fashion think of firewalls
typically firewalls have been deployed
at the perimeter they were potentially
choke points and you know they didn't
scale very well with Andromeda
architecture our firewall rules are
actually deployed directly on our
compute engines the ingress and the
egress there is connection tracking and
and that's the way we are able to scale
because there is no choke point all the
firewall rules are deployed directly on
the compute engines per se so to
summarize there is no choke point you
know it's stateful with connection
tracking and we also support flexible
grouping mechanisms for tags and service
accounts so now we've seen services such
as firewalls load balancers and routers
being deployed using Andromeda I'm going
to segue into a new topic but that's
very relevant how do you scale with
Andromeda remember when I had made a
reference to it being a global network
well global networks are big you also
have to remember that a lot of our users
are fortune 100 clients and a lot of
large internet companies with very large
internet-based workloads so they're asks
for a network having 100k + VMs in
addition to you know having more
networks
another point to note is that it's not
just the size of the network or the
number of networks there's also the
concern of how do you provision a large
network really really fast so if we take
of use cases such as MapReduce or
tensorflow there is a need to provision
a really large network really really
fast how do you do that
so the way we do that is with using
hoverboards hoverboards are in essence a
software gaping if you come from the
routing world think of it as a top of
racks way I mean think of it as a route
reflector a BGP route reflector if you
come from the switching world think of
it as a top of rack switch right which
is essentially forwarding information
for all the flows of course it'll you
know it's a it's a dedicated software
instance you can have larger forwarding
tables the virtual switches themselves
have essentially you know their default
gate the hoverboards the default gateway
default routes from the virtual switch
itself to the hoverboard right very
standard so with this way you can scale
your control pane the reason programming
time is not significant because see all
your programming is a small subset of
hoverboards as opposed to programming
every switch as you can see the order of
difference in terms of programming time
last but not the least it's important to
note that this if you're getting control
plane scalability there's a trade-off in
data plane scalability because you are
having to provision your data plane to
deal with the peak bandwidth you have to
provision the hoverboard to deal with
that peak bandwidth of all the flows so
how do we get around that requirement
for supporting the peak bandwidth of all
the flows that has to go through the
hoverboard
well the way they do it is we
essentially offload some high bandwidth
flows to the virtual switches directly
right so we essentially program we
detect that a flow is very high
bandwidth
and we program it directly to go from
the virtual switch to the virtual switch
itself and offload the hoverboard in
this way we get both control plane
scalability as well as data plane
scalability right so but how does this
work really why does it work
we went and studied all the network
flows in our data center all the
east-west flows and we noticed is that
most VM pairs don't really talk to each
other and very few if they do talk to
each other have very low bandwidth
requirements it's only an extremely
small amount that has really high
bandwidth flows amongst them so those
are the ones we offload from the
hoverboard to the V switches themselves
right now going back to just this point
about why does it take is it quicker to
provision the hoverboards right because
you have only a small subset of these
software switches that you have to
provision so the programming time you
know is nice and lynnium but think about
pre programming all the virtual switches
with all the forwarding rules it
essentially starts out as a quadratic
growth in terms of programming time but
slowly you know if you are in a specific
zone and a lot of VMs share the same
physical host the programming time then
becomes linear but it's too late
I mean you've already exceeded the
programming time with the quadratic
growth so effectively with hoverboards
we are able to see a 37 percent
improvement in programming time for
large networks we've started
implementing routing features on the
hoverboard additional features such as
load balancing and other firewall
features are in progress of development
now I'm going to hand it over to all
who's going to show you a real I'll be
in action
in this demo here that we have prepared
yet is to show you guys a real use case
with some of the features that Bobby was
covering and delivered using Andromeda
so we have an automated deployment with
multiple V PC networks as you guys can
see here so three p pc networks one
called dmz another one project or the
one dev those V pcs are being connected
by multi Nick Linux firewalls and
connect and in those V pcs there there
are also internal load balancers
attached to manage instance groups doing
auto scaling so with this demo here what
we are going to show is the autoscaler
in action showing the ILB with the
preserved client IP that Bobby mentioned
so there is no proxy in the middle so
connections from the client go directly
to the to the servers we are also going
to show in the the service discovery the
DNS name for the il B which is a new
feature and how to monitor all of that
with a stack driver so here in the
beginning
let me just increase this here so what
we are going to show is first the
networks being defined so the three
networks that I mentioned they've
brought in DMZ with different segments
now defining the final rules which are
defined at the VP sea level but enforced
at the instance level so one of the
rules the last one are the health checks
they are required for the il be and next
instance is that we have so we have the
the bastion that we are going to use for
access the load test VMs to generate
traffic and a single a web server in
this first step just to show you guys
the performance that we are going to
generate and blast at VM and so just to
show you here those there are two mix
both of them with auto scaling off and
web server mig there is just a single
instance or our scaling off so a single
it's not going to
water scale next
what we are going to show here is a
start having a providing axis just to
show that this is a live environment so
the real IP for example for this first
Linux Faro is getting through the GCL B
and then go into the Linux Faro so this
is the the nice landing page one thing
that I just wanted to highlight it's
doing that so that's why you can you do
not see the XF after but you do see the
client real client IP now there is a GCL
be configured to deliver this service as
well
so the real that you shall be the
external IP that is providing the load
balancing across the Pharos if we hear
it you guys will see a difference which
is the exported for header because the G
shall be is a is a proxy based service
so that's that's the main difference
just to show you guys that both services
are the services are available through
both G shall be and the direct connected
IP now we are going to connect here to
the bastion to the bastion host and
start basically two connections one to
the web server and another one to the
load test so we can generate traffic and
show you what a single instance can
deliver one one important thing also to
note and I will highlight here during
the demo is I have two web servers
loaded so one of them is showing
responding to port 80 which is the one
that you saw there which is a very very
small page so low request and the other
one is 8080 which is running a high
process so here I'm just showing a
command just to show you guys that these
this VM is programmed to respond to
packets destined to the ILB which is the
1001 10 as you guys can see there so
that's how we can show that the the IP
the packets are delivered to the server
they reach directly the server they do
not flow through any any middle layer
now we are going to show here the
servers that I mentioned so there are
two servers one listening on 8080
another one on 80 on 80 it's that that
simple landing page - oh and on 80 80
it's actually a fractal so I'm going to
start started here a CPU utilization
monitor as you guys can see there are
pretty much no utilization and I'll
generate some traffic since this web
server is running a fractal so there's a
lot of CPU utilization so I'll generate
two sessions actually which is here the
command so it'll be 20 sessions with
rate of 2 per second and so we can see
that the CPU spiking close to 85% so and
again this is using a very CPU intensive
server so once we do that we are going
now back to the MiG to show to change
the config of the MiG so we can show the
auto scaling and just before that if I
if I issue here the command with with
the watch so we can take a look at the
the open connections and generate the
the sessions again then we are going to
see that the commands targeting now the
IO B will be the so the first is
starting the real IP right so the IP
from 0.5 targeting the dot 6 the next
one that is going to be done here is
generating traffic targeting the IO ba
address which is this DNS here being
highlighted so that's the DNS entry that
was created was defined when create when
creating the ID ilb so sending packets
should that il be then we can see that
actually the packet monitor I will be
done here in the next so first a curl
just to make sure that that il be is
responding to the traffic and now we
fight when I start generating that
traffic then we'll be able to see in the
connection tracking that the target IP
is 1001 10 which is the il be so that VM
once it's part of a managed instance
group tied to the internal load
balancing is programmed to respond to
packets destined directly to the il be
and one thing to highlight here is that
the number of sessions which was around
2000 connections per second was the same
number
targeting directly the web server or
targeting the ILB so there is no choke
point in the middle so now we are going
to configure the instance group and
increase and increase the max size
actually enable the autoscaler
so we go to the Meg added the the
managed instance group enable auto
scaling and set the target CPU
utilization to 80 percent increase the
number of instances to 6 and reduce the
cooldown so cooldown period is the
number of seconds before the instance is
seen as ready to receive traffic so we
are going to change that just so it
improves our demo but in real life you
should monitor that and see the amount
of time that you need before your
instance is ready to receive traffic now
I have started the CP utilization I'm
just to show here that it was changed
already so it's ready to receive traffic
and if you take a look at the monitoring
in the console we can see that there is
one instance and the total CPU usage
will be available as take a few seconds
but will be available as 80 percent
which is the the threshold that we have
set once I start generating the traffic
which is here so twelve hundred sessions
with a rate of four per second then I'll
bless the CPU for this machine and we'll
have to wait a little bit until that the
make eggs in so now switching to stack
driver I have created this custom
dashboard that will show the pervy mCP
utilization plus all the ILB statistics
so we can monitor but also if we go here
directly to the instances we can see a
list of all the instances that's going
to load here with a CP utilization now
we are seeing just one because of course
takes a few seconds until the may kicks
in the the new instances are created and
the CPU is loaded we can also see this
new feature I don't know if you guys if
you guys are aware but in stack driver
we have loaded several metrics and and
available already in stack driver for
the IO B so we can see all the
throughput the packets inbound outbound
latency for doing a breakdown by
instance group for example by server or
showing all the key metrics here so it's
everything available already in
stackdriver this is built in there is
nothing that needs to be customized to
see this and then you can break down by
several parameters here several options
and then take a look at it
similarly I'm just to just to show you
guys here we also have metrics available
for GCL B it's not the focus of this
presentation we have others specifically
covering the the Google cloud load
balancer but so you guys see there's a
there's several metrics already built in
into stackdriver to a lot of monitoring
now what I have done is a build a custom
dashboard to monitor all the my main
servers so I'm grouping all servers are
named by prod Meg and also I of all the
IOB related statistics so we can see
here that the the one VM that the stack
driver seen already has a spike here on
CPU has a high CPU utilization so once
we go back now to the console we can
take a look and see if the the stairs
are of the Meg and if it's increasing
already yeah
so doing a reload then we can see here
that not yet but the members are
actually being spun up so just one thing
the VMS are being spun up soon they will
they soon they will be ready after the
cooldown period after those 15 seconds
and they will be ready to see to receive
traffic so once they are ready to
receive traffic after it's up and
running in those 15 seconds the the VMS
is reported that was running and after
those 15 seconds they are configurable
then we are going to see the traffic
being loaded distributed to all the VMS
and will see the via mutualization for
this first one being reduced so so will
be distributed so it takes a few seconds
so also so you guys know the Meg is
pretty quick to kick in how
ever it takes into account the last 10
minutes of VM utilization to take
decisions we scale up or scale down so
that's why it takes a few minutes for to
actually make the decision but now we
you guys can see so it has increased
already to 240 percent I believe to 3
CPUs so if we reload here we'll be able
to see the CPU information and
utilization so the VMS are already
loaded here and available with with the
CPU utilization soon and now back to the
to the GCP console once we refresh we
are going to see this utilization
growing to actually four hundred and
eighty percent which would be the six
VMs that I have configured times 80
percent of available CPU utilization
so that there are well here in this demo
I'm using the CPU as a metric to provide
the auto scaling but you could also use
for example custom stackdriver metrics
to do this auto scaling so stackdriver
supports custom metrics you can build on
your own you can install agents on your
servers to monitor the parameters
they're more important for you and then
you scale up based on that scale up and
scale down so now as you can see here we
can see all the other VMs ready and
utilization of 204 virtualization of
200% power of 240 percent which are
three VMs ten times eighty and now we
see that the the CPU utilization in the
first VM is reduced because now the
traffic is being spread across more VMs
so we'll do some refresh here so to see
the updated the updated information now
I think in the next one all the VMS will
be ready and we'll see four hundred and
eighty percent CPU utilization available
that could be used will then do a do
sort of a I will do a fast Ford just
because it takes 10 minutes taking into
account the last 10 minutes you scale
down so you guys can see that after
traffic is stabilized
I stopped generating traffic here then
we'll see the utilization going down
again and then scaling down the servers
and back to normal life so and just to
show you here what would look like in
stackdriver
so in stack driver it takes a few
seconds to get that information and load
in the graph so it's starting to load
here and create a nice graph for you
will evolve the CP utilization and and
the data
yeah so now the capacity is 480 percent
and reduced to 120 percent utilization
average so one one thing that is
important the CP utilization that we
configure here is an average it's not a
total per CPU but at a verge calculated
of all of all the CPUs and now going
back to my smart to my dashboard my
custom dashboard so I have all the CPUs
now added here with a with the
utilization on a per CPU basis so it can
be monitored and and all the data and
you can also set the alerts here from
stackdriver so now back to the MiG we
can see there are all the mix all the
servers were created one thing one thing
that I would like to highlight here is
that I'm using a regional MIG so as you
guys can see the there are two instances
per zone two in central b2 and central
1c so we were providing zonal redundancy
as well so trafficking is being
distributed in the same region across
multiple zones
then now that's the first four that I
mentioned if we go back and check now on
the details the auto scaling is on but
the number of instances is one and then
they're scaled down over time at the
course of that those ten minutes it's
going to decrease the utilization and
then scales down back to one one VM as
you guys can see there in the graph now
back to Bobby so what this means for you
remember the global network we support
resiliency with live migration and we
support scale and performance right we
hope we've shown you some aspects of the
Andromeda architecture how it allows
your network services to scale to
reliable and they're really fast one
more thing
we are just announcing in alpha support
for 32 gigabit networking of course you
need the skylake cpu platform but you
don't need custom drivers and you need
16 V CPU or higher so these are some of
our GCP networking sessions that I'd
like you to check out upcoming and of
course you can check them out the Encore
versions on YouTube in addition if you
would like a cloud poster a 36 inch by
50 inch showing the Google's global
network please sign up and then you'll
get one free shipped to you in the
continental US
[Music]